last fall as part of operation riptide
valve set out to solve a long-standing
grievance with one of counter-strike's
oldest and undoubtedly most iconic maps
now the fix was simple allow cts to
safely cross mid-doors from spawn by
erecting a measly seemingly innocuous
overhang that blocks it the issue is
that as far as anyone can tell
that one overhang
ruined
everything with tees unable to move
anywhere the a1s mowing them down
whenever they do and the map's pick rate
plummeting
everyone's kind of wondering the same
thing
did valve ruin dust too
[Music]
all right so like the video subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications
that's it that's all i got
i i have to fill more time
oh
um
all right
here's a clip of uh me being kenny s
real quick they need to go big and
kenny's gonna go ahead and peek in a
second minute he gets the flick on his
lightning fast
okay so unless you've been living under
a rock for the last six months you are
surely aware of the fact that about six
months ago the cs go devs implemented
what is quite literally the first real
substantial structural rework that dust2
has ever seen if you would like to learn
more about how and why dust2 went 20
years without a rework and just the
history of this absurdly popular map be
sure to check out the story of we did on
it it is a stellar piece of media and i
say that without a single trace of bias
even though i wrote it so what was the
grievance i spoke of well it is safe to
say that everyone and i mean everyone
from silvers to seasoned professionals
have at some point in the past 20 years
experienced said grievance i am of
course speaking of the infamous and
iconic
mid-doors spam niko will start them off
rain and broken to finish question is
can they actually go kill initially yes
they can come on guys come on
for those who don't know dust2 has
always been structured in such a way
that the cts couldn't leave the right
side of their spawn without crossing mid
doors this meant that in order to do so
safely they'd have to jump juke or
ideally burn a smoke which let's be
honest was stupid so after eons of
annoyance the cs go devs decided to do
something about it and as mentioned at
the outset the solution was very simple
insert a visibility inhibiting overhang
which if you haven't laid eyes on is
essentially a non-wallbangable connector
type thing did it prevent the tees from
spawn scoping down mid
not really did it turn counter-strike's
most traditionally t-sided trouncing
grounds into something a little less
oppressive for defenders
oh yeah did it upend the map and turn it
into a needlessly punishing hellscape
for teas
pretty much now to be fair for those
who've been paying attention and playing
counter-strike regularly for the last
six months this isn't news
very soon after the rework countless
competitors and casters and community
figures took to twitter to voice their
criticisms and complaints about what a
big deal this was actually going to be
for starters teas have to drop suicide
to spot both the doors themselves and
the mid to lower ton sprint which means
the cts have an insane amount of freedom
when it comes to denying map control
early on because the teas still need to
try their luck long if they want a
refined way to finish the round and if
they don't
then well this happens
he's coming his way one maybe even more
zoe who's knocked down the door needs
more
apex finally silences him but boomich
that's high impact two rounds in a row
and if and when the t's finally do get
said control
it's usually at the cost of a ton of
time and some bodies and they've
achieved what is essentially the bare
minimum also important to note that the
t's are doing all of this against the
new and improved laser beam that is the
a1s which was also buffed about six
months ago in case you've been out of
the loop as of late the silencer is back
and it's basically a death ray there did
you see it
run back kyogen's draw animation slowly
see how the homie starts unequipping the
silencer by mistake i've been saying for
ages that they need to give that [ __ ] a
separate key bind and no one has taken
me seriously y'all trying to gaslight me
into thinking you have to be a nova to
fat finger your right click all right
but there you have it on the main stage
of a major
i'm all worked up now all right you're
happy
anyway this is all to say the dust 2 is
definitely undergoing some tough scenes
right now the pros seemingly detest it
as evinced by the fact that if you look
it up on hltv you will see that over the
past six months its pick rate has
dropped faster than an ak in the
vicinity of an a1s but [ __ ] don't take
my word for it listen to my close
personal friend eric flahm explain to
you just exactly how this map has turned
into a cesspool
of force by driven despair
bomb does look like my high school
janitor
how [ __ ] is that man
sorry uh
wrong clip
i must have uh
popped that one in my accident
dimitri dude hey dimitri i will [ __ ]
ban you bro i swear to god i clipped
that like seven months ago and i've just
gotten so much mileage out of it since
anyway
here is the actual explanation
coin flip long is all you can do you
can't even rush b without getting killed
by a guy lower you actually didn't
prevent people from getting sniped on
cross you just made mid entirely way too
easy for cts you slowed down a map that
isn't tactical
so you basically didn't change anything
with the map except give cts more space
and more areas to disrupt
you emphasize the worst thing about the
map which is the fact that long a is a
coin flip and the most important part of
dust too
and you've slowed down a map that
doesn't have any tactical depth to it
besides baiting rotates after cat
control so yeah memes aside it does seem
as if the dust 2 changes just sort of
definitively
suck
it's obviously still relatively early
and we may still see teams sort of
innovate ways to circumvent the rework
but until that happens
or until valve decides to revert the
changes or make new changes and it's
valve so who knows if and when that'll
happen
the map isn't likely to see a ton more
action is dust too dead
no
it's dust too you can't kill dust2 but
will it remain unpopular and maybe even
out of commission for the foreseeable
future
i don't know
i hope not i've always been a really big
fan of dust2 and i'd sooner rather see
mirage or inferno take a hit than the
good old dust bowl for now we'll just
have to wait and see what teams do with
it and by extension what valve does with
it do valve revert the changes do they
implement new changes or replace the map
altogether with say
tuscan i don't know
but it's interesting to see the
counter-strike map pool on such a weird
precipice
there's sort of this like old adage in
gaming it like transcends esports it's
like just a gaming thing where like
if there's a map maker that exists like
if you can make a map in a game dust2 is
in it like you can play dust2 in
fortnite you can play minecraft you can
play it in rocket league like whatever
like they someone has made a dust too
like in like literally every game
imaginable